all right tonight we start with
explosive news from our own catherine
herridge the memos that Jim Comey leaked
to the media that ultimately became the
catalyst his desire for the appointment
of special counsel robert muller they
were more widely shared than he
previously disclosed last year Comey
told Congress that he leaked this memo
to his friend professor Daniel Richmond
at Columbia University now tonight
sources are revealing that commis
current lawyer longtime friend Patrick
Fitzgerald you may remember the school
delivery case was also given this
potentially classified information in
these documents and sources are also
claiming that Comey may have leaked the
memos to yet another unnamed individual
just moments ago here's how James Comey
tried to explain all of these leaks that
he never told us about before I sent one
memo unclassified then still
unclassified and it's recounted in my
book to my friend Dan Richmond and asked
him to get the substance of it but not
the memo out to the media
separately I wrote a bunch of memos
about my interactions with President
Trump and I was what was called an
original classification authority of the
FBI meaning I had the training and the
authority to make decisions about what
should be classified what shouldn't some
of those memos I decided to be
classified for others I wrote them and
was highly confident they should not be
classified those four I kept a copy the
FBI and a copy of my personal safe at
home after I was fired I put together
legal team of three people one of whom
was Professor Dan Richmond at Columbia
University after I had asked him to give
this information to the media I
separately gave my legal team four memos
which were unclassified the bottom line
is I see no credible claim by any
serious person that that violated the
law yeah that's like Obama say no
serious person can think Russia could
ever have any tampering in our elections
now contrary to what Comey just said in
just moments we will have multiple
credible individuals including former US
Attorney Joe digenova shine some light
on call me serious misdeeds now CNN went
on to press call me on his potentially
illegal leaking amazing watch this you
did leak memos I mean is it okay for
or somebody at the FBI to leak something
an internal document even if it's not
classified isn't that leaking well
there's a whole lot wrong with your
question Anderson first I didn't leak
memos I asked a friend to communicate
the substance of one unclassified man
whether you can every sector okay one
unclassified memo to the media and I was
really important I was a private citizen
I was not an FBI employee it was an
internal document it was a document
you'd written while you were FBI
director that that is a li I mean if you
tell somebody don't give them the
document but tell them what's in the
document that's still a leak no well not
to get tangled up in it I think of a
leak as an unauthorized disclosure of
classified information really I did as
the Anderson had been secretly watching
this show now remember in June of last
year James Comey made no mention of this
during his testimony before Congress
take a look did you show copies of your
memos to anyone outside of the
Department of Justice yes and to whom
did you show copies
I asked president tweeted on Friday
after I got fired that I better hope
there's not tapes I woke up in the
middle of the night on Monday night
because it didn't dawn on me originally
that there might be corroboration for
our conversation there might be a tape
and my judgment was I needed to get that
out into the public square and so I
asked a friend of mine to share the
content of the memo with a reporter
didn't do it myself for a variety of
reasons I asked him to because I thought
that might prompt the appointment of a
special counsel and so I asked a close
friend of mine to do it and was said mr.
Witt Asst no no who was that a good
friend of mine who's a professor at
Columbia Law School now remember he was
under oath that means even more jeopardy
for Jim Comey tonight and was James
Comey withholding information from
Congress did he lie by omission now this
is damning the revelations that are
surrounding whether or not the fired FBI
director acted in an unethical and
potentially illegal way after he was
fired and tonight we can confirm at the
office for the inspector general is
investigating Jim Comey the disgraced
former FBI director for months on this
program we have been predicting that Jim
Comey could well in fact be facing
serious
legal consequences for these actions and
earlier this week the president weighed
in remember he wrote James Comey
illegally leaked classified documents to
the press in order to generate a special
counsel
therefore the special counsel will is
established based on an illegal act
really does everybody know what that
means
now even CNN's top liberal legal analyst
a total Lib is weighing in and even he
acknowledges this is not looking good
for Jim Comey what is the president
implying there well well what he's
saying is that when James Comey took
those memos that recounted his
conversations with the President and
gave them to Professor Dan Richman at
Columbia University that was an illegal
leak especially since he considered he
knew that Richmond was going to give
that to the press but also notes about a
conversation with the president taken by
then a private citizen there are those
classified they may or may not be and in
fact when the when the administration
where Congress released those some
versions of those memos some of the
portions were blacked out I think James
Comey actually is in a pretty vulnerable
position here just because something is
not marked classified doesn't mean that
after the fact it couldn't be
retroactive Lee designated classified I
think Comey may may really have a
problem there yeah he may have a problem
though there's potential legal jeopardy
is not stopping Comey from living it up
now cashing in on his newfound fame and
fortune the Trump aiding former FBI
director threw himself a big party at
what is called the Newseum in Washington
DC an appropriate venue given that many
of commis honored guests held from the
mainstream media so let's hope Jim Comey
made a good impression after all we do
know this book tour and this media blitz
is just one big tryout for homies future
career if he wants one as a pundit on
conspiracy TV MSNBC or fake news CNN now
one more breaking story to bring you Fox
News has learned that former New York
City Mayor Rudy Giuliani has now taken
over discussions with the special
counsel robert muller about a possible
interview with the president now Rudy
Giuliani just put out a statement reads
in part
the president has produced 1.2 million
documents that is historically
unprecedented we believe it presents
overwhelming proof that the President
did not collude with regard to the 2016
election remember that's where we're
supposed to start and according to
sources the president is open to
speaking with robert muller and wrapping
up the investigation we're gonna analyze
these new developments later in the show
my advice until Andrew Weissman and
other anti-trump agenda-driven
investigators have fired no way Donald
Trump should do that interview now
remember Weissman described by the New
York Times as Muller's pit bull he
withheld exculpatory evidence multiple
times at several high-profile
convictions overturned on appeal but not
before ruining the lives of tens of
thousands of people and especially at
anderson accounting all right now we
turn to another major breaking story to
judicial watch tonight has released
hundreds of pages brand-new for the
first time unearthed emails from Hillary
Clinton's illicit email server why did
it take this long how is it possible
Hillary Clinton was not charged with
mishandling classified information
because some of the new emails show
these emails were classified now we know
Clinton's server was likely hacked by
multiple foreign governments and now
multiple uncovered emails tonight
contain information so sensitive and
classified they were totally redacted
including this email exchange between
Prime Minister Tony Blair Clinton and
other State Department officials
entitled Mideast peace now next there
was another completely redacted email in
this document even the recipients were
removed the title was of the email was
quote plan and other uncovered emails
also revealed some pretty damning
evidence that the Clinton State
Department was in fact actively
colluding with the Clinton Foundation
and the Clintons constant obsessive
money making schemes in one particularly
disturbing email Clinton campaign
official retrieved a request for a 20 in
2010 asking for advice how to get
through to Bill Clinton about big-money
offer to speak abroad was it Russia
where was it the email was promptly
forwarded to a State Department employee
and even uma Abidine herself
course this restoring Hillary Clinton's
time when she was the Secretary of State
now remember the case of Christian
saucier remember that Navy sailor sailor
recently pardoned by President Trump but
only after he was forced to spend time
in jail
sentenced to a year in jail for
mishandling six pictures he was proud of
because he worked inside a u.s.
submarine meanwhile Hillary Clinton is
mishandling top secret emails from world
leaders nothing and by the way this new
release only accounts for a couple of
hundred emails with the 33,000 that she
deleted an acid-washed and had devices
beaten up with hammers now the Clintons
really want us to believe foreign
entities didn't use the foundation to
influence a sitting Secretary of State
millions of dollars and we're going to
get back to these almost unbelievable
discoveries Tom fitnah Judicial Watch is
here but first it is a new political
landscape in America famed rapper
fashion designer Kanye West has now
issued a very glowing endorsement of
President Trump he took to Twitter
telling his millions of Twitter
followers quote you don't have to agree
with Trump but the mob can't make me not
love him no we both we are both dragon
energy he is my brother I love everyone
I don't agree with everyone any
everything anyone does well that's what
makes us individuals and we have the
right to independent thought and Kanye
West even posted a picture of himself
wearing a make America great again hat
driving liberals on social media totally
insane tonight and get this Kanye is
even slamming former President Obama for
his utter failure in the former
president's own hometown of Chicago
writing quote Obama was in office for
eight years and nothing in Chicago
changed kanye west is absolutely right
we talked about this a lot under the
Obama administration nearly 4,000 people
were murdered on the streets of Chicago
his hometown Obama barely mentioned it
did nothing this was American lies
American treasure lost tragedy travesty
of corpse this all started after Kanye
West publicly stood up for a black
conservative a woman that we had on the
program this week Candace Owens after
many on the Left slammed her remarks at
UCLA
take a look at this what is happening
right now in the black community you're
gonna hear in this room first there's a
an ideological civil war happening black
people at our focus on their past and
shouting about slavery
and black people that are focused on
their future victim mentality is not
cool I don't know why people like being
oppressed so weirdest thing I've ever
heard I love oppression
we're oppressed 400 years of slavery Jim
Crow which by the way none of you guys
live to your grandparents didn't it's
embarrassing that you utilize you
utilize their history you utilize their
history and you come in here with more
emotion than ever have when they were
living through it more emotion than they
ever had when they were living through
it it's embarrassing you're not living
through anything right now you're overly
privileged American amazing moment star
is born and while kanye west takes a
stand for freedom of thought and freedom
of expression we should all support this
over at CNN y of your professional Trump
hater so-called journalist Jim Acosta
well he's doing the exact opposite and
going completely off the rails claiming
that Americans could be inspired by
Trump's rhetoric calling out liberal
media bias and actually commit acts of
violence against the president against
the press does he not remember Madonna's
remarks about desiring and dreaming of
blowing up the White House or the
severed head or any of the other
instances and the anthrax scare watch
this the problem is is that people
around the country don't know it's an
actor they're not you know on the act
and they take what he says very
seriously and they take attacks from
Sean Spicer and Sarah Sanders and and
what they do to us on a daily basis very
seriously they don't have all their
faculties in some cases they're their
elevator might not hit all floors my
concern is is that there's a better
journalist is going to be hurt one of
these days somebody's going to get hurt
and at that point you know the White
House the president United States
they're gonna have to take a hard look
in the mirror and ask themselves whether
or not they played a role in this
how many threats against the president
how many who talks about blowing up the
White House putting up severed heads as
a joke now we have known for some time
that Jim Acosta lives in a paranoid
anti-trump state of delusion that some
call trump derangement syndrome but Jim
Acosta and his friends and the fake news
media they need to wake up
Trump is not the source of all of your
problems and to complain that his honest
discussion about the state of the media
in this country is going to incite
violence that is a step too far and
patently frankly absurd